Chuuuut
La lumière est bonne ici, la lumière est bonne là
Le sujet prend bien la lumière!
*claque x2*
Eh bien bonjour les amis de retour du Japon, je suis avec...
- Senseï Carlito, Senseï Macfly !
- Tu m'as coupé.
Les mecs j'vous ai fait une petite surprise.. j'ai besoin de toucher tes genoux
J'ai ramené des objets d'un magasin qui s'appelle Dolgit
Dolgit c'est quoi? C'est un magasin...
t'imagines Carrefour sur cinq étages.
Et le dernier étage c'est que des bêtises.
Des bêtises!
La valise est là-bas, vu que j'ai la flemme de la ramener s'quon va faire
c'est qu'on ira chacun notre tour chercher un objet
-Ok
Pourquoi aussi loin je ne sais pas
mais elle est vraiment à deux mètres là ...
C'est vrai, on pourrait la mettre là!
Et les deux personnes qui n'iront pas chercher l'objet devront occuper les gens.
-ok -Ouais ! On fait un jeu comme ça . -chi-fou-mi ! quand c'est toi c'est toi qui jouis !
*rires trop abusé de McFly & carlito*
Il est mignon ton petit Shiba que t'as acheté au Japon en voyage avec Maxenss
Non c'est ... c'est c'est ... tu t'es trompé ...
Et bah vous vous ressemblez
Bon les gars 1er objet!
c'est un demi-flingue (*rires*)
Cet objet est extrêmement cool :
c'est une roulette russe, avec des ballons ...
Des fois, ça va taper le ballon.
Quand ça le tape, le ballon va péter.
j'veux pas faire le relou du fond de la classe de la video mais on dit pas "des fois", on dit "parfois".
Pour ceux qui ont vu "voyage au bout de l'enfer", avec De Niro...
MAIS TA GUEULE MAIS PUTAIN MAIS FERME LA ! PUTAIN !
*rires* et *gonfle le ballon* - oui !
Ce moment me plaît!
Ok t'es prêt, tu commences !
Tu dois le mettre proche de ton oreille et appuyer sur la détente !
*This Is The End*
*crient et rigolent*
*Reprise de la musique*- J'ai peur de rien je suis un héros .
allez !!!!
Oh putain c'est moi ...
On a survécu-u on a survécu-u
*Musique de suspense encore une fois*
Plus près ! Plus près de ton oreille!
*Squeezie gueule comme une meuf*
*clic*
YES *crient et rigolent*
J'avais tellement peur !
*encore une fois la musique*
*clic*
WOOHOO -OH LA CHATTE
Dites à ma mère ... que ma collection One Piece il ne faut pas la toucher !
*PAN* - AHHHHHH -oh mais nan c'est pas possible...
*PAN*et*BOOM* *crient et rigolent*
HAHAHA putain !!
Pourquoi c'est toujours moi ?!
Hey premier objet, j'aurai peut être du en prendre un autre parce que c'est l'un des meilleurs
McFly: j'vais le chercher - allez vas-y !
T'as pris quoi?
Mais nan mais ça mec j'me suis trompé de ..
-Oh c'est pour ton Shiba !?
-Oui...
C'est pour mon chien c'est un jouet il avait le même là où il est
-Putain tu l'aimes tellement ton chien t'as vérifié si t'étais pas stérile?
*saturation*
Alors ça ! Qui n'a pas de barbe parmi nous ? personne ! Donc cet objet, est-ce qu'il a un interêt ?
La réponse est non!
Bah on peut le porter le reste de la video.
-Ok.
*Seinfield theme*
OhOHOHOHAHAHA
Ok les mecs, c'est simple, ça va être un match !
De quelque chose de pas ridicule, c'est un sport certifié par le Japon!
C'est faux!
*Happy Together - Turtles*
Alors !
On comptera le nombre de balles à la fin qu'il y aura dans la tête de l'autre.
Mais on doit se les mettre nous-même?
Non ! Moi j'les mets dans toi et toi tu les mets à moi?
Moi j'les mets dans toi, et ensuite c'est bon !
J'aime quand tu me la mets !
OH MAIS ! La p'tite blague de cul là qui pass... *Claque*
*Donk!*
Heureusement c'est du Made in Japan, c'est très solide!
*jingle marketing*
Ok !
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire?
J'te montre :
What the fuck, ouais !
A toi
*NOPE*
*voix robotique dans le rythme* Bienvenu dans cette partie de ping-pong tête qui oppose actuellement...
-Enfin y'a même plus de joie quand il le dit !
Jean-Juan Carlito qui vient du Brésil à...
Lucas Hauchard
AH FUCK !
*rire*
Le mec il a pas honte ...
Alors! nouvel objet les amis ! C'est ...
-Ah
-Tu viens de faire quoi ? Tu sors
Nouvel objet ... Nan mais c'est une blague Raphael
-Ah ! Ba elle est marante cette blague !
-Ok les mecs nouvel objet
Alors j'ai pris des risques en ramenant ça parce qu'il contient de la poudre euh.. pour faire finalement exploser des billets de dix mille yens Le principe est très simple quand je vais tirer su cette corde
y'aura un maximum de billets qui vont tomber
Des vrais billets dedans ?
OUI PUTAIN !
-MAIS M'ENGUEULE PAS !
PUTAIN LE PÉDAGOGUE
Qui tire sur la ficelle ?
Moi, j'adore tirer sur les ficelles !
POP !!!
HAAAAA !!!
LA TUNE !!! X4
OH, ça sent bon, alors moi j'adore l'odeur
*renifle*
OH, ça sent BONHAAAAAA !!!!!!
L'odeur du souffre !!!
Calme toi
*rire*
Mais mec, je pensais que les billets étaient taille réel, par contre
Y a eu une petite arnaque *rire*
On passe à la suite !
Alors ce bureau-euh-va brûler avant la fin de la vidéo
C'est vraiment le bordel
Si l'objet est une fausse rose, je pleure de rire
Alors, c'est une rose que tu offres à ta copine, et en fait dans la rose
(L'objet dans la fleur est tombé) *rire*
Chaque objet est cassé ou cassable
C'est fait exprès, dans la rose se cache une culotte
AAAHHH
C'est tout
Carlito: C'est 2 objet ?
Squeezie: Oui *Rires*
Mc Fly: Ah ! Je remplace !  Carlito: Il y a aucune spécificité !
Squeezie : Nan mais le p.. Vous avez pas compris
Le principe c'est que tu offres une rose et en fait dedans se cache une culotte.
Carlito : Ah! C'est genre un truc romantique avec du sexe dedans ?Squeezie : Oui
Carlito : Ah bah waouh beau niveau super !
Squeezie : Tant qu'on est dans le pétard, et je parle pas de canabiiiiiiiiis  Mc Fly : Woooooooouh
Squeezie : Ca vous dit quelque chose ? Mc Fly: M72A non ?
Carlito : C'est une bouteille de ... Squeezie (en coupant Carlito) : Alors en fait c'est la même chose que le truc d'avant sauf que c'est censé faire un maximum de bruit.
Mc Fly : Houla ouais non c'est peut-être dangereux ça !
*Squeezie fait exploser le tube* Mc Fly (en criant) : AAAAAAAAh !
*Rires étouffés de Squeezie et Mc Fly*
Mc Fly : Ouais Squeezie : *Paroles incompréhensibles*
*Rires de Mc Fly puis de Squeezie*
*Carlito renifle le tube* Mc Fly ( en lui prenant la main) : Nan mais mec ! *Puis rires de Carlito*
Squeezie : Bon ! Mc Fly : Un peu de retenue un peu de calme on s'assoit et on travaille s'il vous plait !
Raphaël  ! Tu te met en slip et tu m'enfiles ça !
Avec plaisir !!
Mc Fly : Pendant ce temps là on va combler !
Ah naaaaaan ! Mec !
*Mc Fly appuie sur la détente*
*Clic*
Squeezie : T'es mort ! *Clic*
Moi je trouve ça un peu violent les gars ! *Rire ponctué de Squeezie*
Mc Fly: Ecoute moi, sois doux, ça va bien se passer, je vais te raconter une histoire...
*Squeezie le coupe*  Tu fais ça pour me le faire brutalement.(voix tremblotante)
Mc Fly: C'est une histoire douce avec un petit lapin qui...
*Clic*
Mc Fly: Ouuuuhouu
Squeezie(en criant):AAAAHHH
*Clic*x2
Mc Fly/Squeezie(en criant): AHHH *Clic* DUAHHHHH/AHHH *Clic*
Sqeezie(en criant): AHYES
*Clic*
Squeezie/Mc Fly: AHHH
*Rigolent*
Squeezie:  :o   /    *Carlito arrive furtivement par derrière*
Mc Fly: Non
Squeezie: Il aurait dû péter ! En faite il a péter..
Mc Fly: Non.   Squeezie:Si si ! Regarde, regarde y'a le..
Squeezie: Y'a le..*Carlito fixe la caméra avec un regard vide*
* Se retournent*  *Se rendent compte de la présence de Carlito*  *Explosent de rire*
*Carlito explose aussi de rire*
Tu es maintenant le titan colossal
CARLITO: he franchemant ca fait plaisir SQUEEZIE :NIQUE SA MERE (x2)
Mac Fly: Et surtout on dirait que t'as des muscles. surtout,
ça fait...ça fait les abdos
Carlito: Ouais après j'ai une bonne base
*Jingle blague de merde au trombone*
Squeezie: OK !!  Pour fêter nos retrouvailles
parce que dix jours sans vous au Japon les gars
je me suis senti tellement mal
Carlito: moi aussi grave pendant que t'étais pas là j'ai ouais
j'ai, j'ai vraiment badé
Squeezie: bon ça c'est simple c'est un objet, un ustensile vraiment apprécier pour faire la fête
Mac Fly: oui oui oui ho la la qu'est_ce que c'est bien ça me plait déja
Squeezie: donc là je suis content, pour fêter ça
*Squeezie souffle et les ballons se gonflent*
*rire*
Carlito: Et Lucas, tu viens de gagner six cent millions d'euros au loto
*HOURRA!*
Carlito: Lucas tu as reçu un message heu...sexy de Harry Roselmack
* Yé!*
Mac fly * en criant*: Lucas ton père vient de mourir
* Génial!!*
*rire*
Squeezie: Alors les mecs, est ce que vous l'appréciez ce Jackie Chan?
Mac Fly: ho oui  * Carlito le dit aussi*
Squeezie : Je lui ai acheté un copain
*Applaudissement de Mac Fly*
squeezie: Voulez-vous découvrir la tête de l'acteur en question s'il vous plait
Mac Fly: on peut, on peut chercher
Squeezie: oui vous pouvez chercher
Carlito: Des indices?
Mac Fly: il est heu..il est heu européen
Squeezie: il pèse, il pèse énormément heu voila
Carlito : "Américain?" *Squeezie confirme* McFly: "Leonardo Di Caprio?" *Squeezie répond non*
Voici le corps!
Ils ont un truc au Japon avec les gros seins
Non, non...
Merde, j'ai pris un pantalon trop petit
Je peux pas pousser plus loin.
C'est pas stretch?
st-ce que tu veux que je tienne la figurine?
Toi t'as l'habitude de...de désapper tes meufs, toi hein
Je fais souvent ça avec ma fille
*bide*
BIM!
YES le corps est pret!
bouge ton body -musique-
Lucas, Lucas...wowowowow
Ça va aller, hein?
C'est bon je m'en charge
HÉÉ Raphaël, Raphaël !
C'EST CHEZ LES FEM...C'EST CHEZ LES FEMMES !
*MUSIQUE YEAAAAH*